okay baby it's your boy psychobabble and
today we're doing a lot of tests to see
if psychobabble will get crazy or not I
mean anglish always English or American
so to speak I lost rican-american
anyway this is more machine a test to
say if you're crazy
actually now it's just to see your moles
fall in line with general population and
basically it's supposed to be for
helping a more dilemma that some caring
cars are gonna have to face so the
self-driving car should it protect the
passenger at all times even if that
means killing a lot of people or should
it just kill the passenger if it means
going to save more lives you know like
if there's one person in the car and
there's five people ahead of you should
the course work through and kill this
guy to save the five people that kind of
thing so let's say if I'm crazy or if
I'm a perfect machine there we go okay
lecture the self-driving cars you tell
yourself or go out here way to kill tell
yourself kill these people or go out of
your way to kill these people jealous
ooh Wow kill doggies I cannot PayPal
well I'm not gonna kill the dogs of
course and they're in the [ __ ] wrong
way okay you know I'm not gonna go out
of my way to kill myself so Duke if I
gotta go okay got it way to kill this
old man I'll kill this baby you just
[ __ ] rather than to the road that's
the bad thing okay
oh it's AG do not walk in these [ __ ]
are walking besides it's better than for
another way killing these people that
are supposed to walk so here okay I'm
not going on my way to kill someone else
some [ __ ] dumbass yep not gonna win a
murder okay it's these people of course
oh I do not I don't not go to way to a
doorway to kill myself so here see why
the people to is that was kind of that
bad why is the dogs driving
oh my god
this is [ __ ] interesting uh well
isn't liking dogs jiving okay well these
people get a go I don't like that thing
where it's like people the size of
different periods of life so I think
these lives are just important to these
ones so these ones going to go books get
and I want to kill a person I can last
one okay
most of characters the dog most killed
characters the outlining saving more
lives protecting passengers applying law
avoid any intervention gender preference
avoid intervention manage a lot
upholding law doesn't automatic gender
preference we can [ __ ] it all the way
and avoid intervention Jenna preference
is males females dying pets
I really prefer pets I guess aids
preference I prefer older Fitness holy
[ __ ] alright well that's out oh my god
very cool
alright I guess I'm a good person thank
you